oh my God oh my God oh my God oh my God
hello everybody my name is markip BL and
welcome back to the Carousel enjoy a
ride on the classic Fazbear antique
Carousel may require technical support
cuz that's what you want your passengers
to do technical support for your ride
that's
broken I thought I was riding it fix all
the broken fuses then replace any broken
switches and turn on the power yeah
repair the circuit board don't forget to
solder new wires with the soldering gun
oh yeah oh this is what I would expect
children to do when they first go to a
ride parel is out of service and we'll
require repairs before we open tomorrow
oh my God that is the end of my
instruction if I had been programmed
with the knowledge to fix it it would
have already been done oh my God oh my
God oh my god well this is
horrible I hate that okay what am I
doing all right so we got a broken
go around broke
down
hi okay all right so I got to do that
now why do I have to hold it this way
why can't I hold it all tactical and
cool maybe I'll just yeah I'll just do
this all right fuse I
guess is that behind me oh yeah it was
you get out of here what are you doing
being all silly like
that get out there
all right fuses are fixed oh outer ring
is
going hi oh I see oh well that makes it
more difficult okay all right so we got
some kind broken switch there
what where you at where was
that huh what do you
mean who's laughing oh oh I see you over
there oh I see it this would be hell if
I didn't have a wireless uh thing going
on here all right switch it's past your
bedtime it's past your shut up
time all right so I'll just wait for him
to come over there all right we got that
there that
there uh-huh oh
God who who what and
where hello oh God where you at oh there
you are don't get any
closer all right then you go there all
right that's two stages
going time uh-huh oh yeah tell me more
about how you can't handle my tactical
style where'd you go where are
you is that you no oh my god there you
are no no no no no no no no not today
yeah get out of here get out all right
so I need to resolder a circuit board oh
God and that I guess I got to solder it
first
what it's gone I don't know why I
deserve
that perfect right oh I got to lay the
wires down I see I see okay lay the
wires in
first oh it's gone okay lay the wires in
first over
here and then solder
it okay and then like like
oh I got to take the old one
out
oh what do you mean naughty naughty
where you at where you at where you
at whoa where are you at I don't see you
why is there a fire what is that of you
what is that about still oh what is what
is happening time to reset what do you
mean oh my God oh my God where'd it go
hey hey hey hey hey stop stop stop stop
stop stop stop stop stop stop get out of
get out get out get out I freaking got
you I freaking had you I had you I
didn't take you seriously because I
think you were a chump where' you where
are you where are you where are
you where are
you there you
are get out of here so I just got to
survive right while everything catches
fire for some reason because it sure is
I see you over there man that is a fire
where you
at oh there you
are yeah that's what I thought oh my god
I think I'm going to die I saw you I saw
that get out of here get out of here
past your
bedtime past your dead time Ah that's my
fakest laugh ever
oh that's that's my realest laugh ever
oh B got you that's right get out of
here buddy well that was
easy H that was your fake laugh
ever
yay Moon
oh it's all right well I did that so I
can be proud of myself so what is it
about this arcade cabinet that needs
coin but I don't have a coin I thought I
had a coin turns out I do not cuz I I
really wish I had a coin but I I
literally used them all or ate them all
or shov them up my ass good good for
me
okay Captain Foxy's log ride it's about
time I haven't seen foxy anywhere here
it's been a whole bunch of nothing oh
shoot the
tar yes yes oh yeah oh yeah I'm just to
Captain Foxy's Cowboy Adventure use them
there has cannons to shoot anything that
moves aim to get a high score or I'll
give you the old tacus Keel Hall have a
rude D time
ye uh-huh thank you at all
time
me oh I love this oh this is awesome
what do you mean sit down what do you
mean I am down I am sat I'm
sitting for
Advent nice nice nice nice in their hole
F fire in whose hole
[Music]
oh I'm doing doing it take that
sheep hello why isn't that not
working I did it take that Woodland
Critters oh it it's back up
again yippe
oh did I do
it
uh
oh
okay I'm
ready I'm oh my God is this supposed to
be this dark oh God
okay one more I'm going to get get the
high score I think I do it like this
it's
helping oh God wait what did I just do
what did I just do the robbery make with
the
loot what did what did I just do did I
did I change up where I was
going did I I didn't know that Elie
would do
that
hello this is kind of cool why is no
other VR game that I've played done like
a water not responsible for anying that
might happen on this
air uh I don't know what path I'm
on oh God who it went dark again I hit
something oh my
God okay oh purple particles in the air
that's that doesn't seem good oh my God
oh my God oh my God oh my oh my God I
didn't know oh that was oh I see I
didn't know that if it was only that
close I guess it makes sense cuz of the
door okay
here oh my God okay good thing that
didn't double press and open it back up
again that would have been very bad I a
is completely off where I was before
whoa oh my God oh my God that seems
lethal oh God what am I doing here oh no
oh what is
this oh wow okay this is not
good oh my God oh my God
okay oh okay all right okay all right oh
my God I got to do both of
these oh God oh God oh God okay you're
just going to close I'm I don't want to
deal with you okay great thank you why
does it keep going to Darkness I don't
like the
darkness haha I don't know what that did
but it's going to do
something if there's one thing that I
can say about myself is I've got an eye
for helpie helpie somewhere I'm going
I'm going to blast helpie overboard what
do you mean
overboard what do you mean overboard
what does overboard mean what do you
mean
overboard
oh God I can't die this far into this
thing okay well that doesn't look
good uh should I be I I should probably
be worried about I'm I'm just going to
go for it you know what I I didn't want
to risk it because I was getting pretty
close to that and whoa what's going on
up there oh not this
again
take that I think I got him whoa tree's
going a little funny tre's going kind of
funny what the freak oh God no I don't
like
that yeah I'm just going for it I I I
know I could have gotten more there but
I I just didn't want to risk
it 8,200 though that's pretty good damn
this a long was friendship all along
oh I hope it was money so what was it
deal with all the purple
lightning what did I get let see how
you oh ah oh yes
yes
a I was so close all right I did it I
guess thanks not quite
admirable I bet if I'd actually gotten
the a few more of those purples it would
have been fine probably over 10,000 is
admirable and I was very close but that
one's a long
one a
[Music]
message
above in the in the skies
above in in the skies above a message
for me in the skies
above the skies
above what do you mean in the skies
above in the skies above I don't exactly
have an inventory so I don't know what
he wants me to
[Music]
do well that's great okay so that's done
this has more to
do sister location is still all virused
up backstage is done so really it's just
the Faz Cade and I want to go to Bonnie
bull VIP bull like a VIP in Bonnie's
private Lane fun bow to get a high score
watch out for random challenges use a
flashlight this isn't balling I'm
supposed to be a
VIP I'm supposed to have my private Lane
I'm okay
that that's different than I was
expecting okie dokie I'm going to bowl
and have a flashlight at the same
time hey
Moon screw
you all right get ready here we
go and
there
damn that was actually way better than I
thought I would be
oh okay creepy all right get ready for
the bowl of
Lifetime ass did I mention I'm not good
at bowling at all I'm I'm
really I'm not a bowler oh whoa
awesome
wait a
minute Get Wrecked all right thanks for
the balls though oh God damn it how you
doing back there you you enjoying the
show I got an audience all right hold
on and the lag on that is a bit much
oh bam that's what I am talking about
I'm doing better than I would in real
life what what what whoa what what what
what in the hell oh my God okay okay get
through get through oh my
god
oh that's what I thought you best back
off you best you best back off three pin
oh I
see o go well it's
all you all right there buddy you okay
bear pal I don't see no
moonman where's moonman supposed to
be thank you oh what
in okay that seems slightly
unfair
okay
I am I doing it
wrong oh my god
oh whoa did I hear that it was at the
[Music]
Gators okay cool awesome now if this
could actually work
properly oh my
God oh my God hey moon man I see you go
away thank
you Moon Man
okay oh my God this is might be the best
bowl of my life and yeah I know that's
sad if you were to look at the score but
if you look at me and how I've developed
as a person you'll notice that the score
is kind of irrelevant to my progress as
a human being so maybe you shouldn't
dwell on things like score and numbers
because that's not a reflection of who a
person is in totality who the freak is
there oh that was the last one okay
um well what are this for oh I see Get
Wrecked eat ass take that one of
those what what no not at the
end
why
oh
oh where was he was he up there I wasn't
looking but I didn't expect him to be
there last frame best frame let's do
this
again was that moonman oh I see he could
be here
anytime that's what I
get oh I'm doing pretty good this time
around not too
bad okay uh I wasn't aiming for your
eyeball but you know if ID have hit it I
wouldn't have
apologized
damn
yes
oh oh it got caught up in your
hair oh man that had to
hurt
oh oh moonman better not ruin this
game ah There Goes My streak okay well I
ruined it myself no one had to to ruin
it for me but I did it don't
worry damn it I've lost
it it was going so good and now I'm just
misunderstood okay I just got to do good
on this last one
right all right here we go do your
thing well no I don't think
so nope okay well this is a problem oh
oh what you deflected my
strike that was oh my God screw
[Music]
you Glam
Bonnie Glam
Bonnie oh my be
devastated oh Glam blond my my
obliterated wow is it really for
True could it really be you are you
truly in the game wait let me get my
height adjusted you
are dead but still cool so how did that
improve my standings not incredibly so
there's only two more things here left
to do that I can do besides that AR
cabinet and this hippo talking to me
about there's something in the clouds
above so I think yeah I'm going to I'm
going to solve that in the very next
episode thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know what you think down
in the comments below uh I'm definitely
doing great not found many gold coins
that's okay I'm going to have to go back
to a lot of these do it all over again
but that's how it goes just building up
my skills getting uh my foot grounding
my ground footing so thank thank you and
as always I will see you in the next
video
[Music]
bye-bye